when there is no distance between who
you are in private and who you are in
public there really is no capacity for
embarrassment if you're not concealing
something about yourself that you're
hoping others will not notice you're not
trying to foist any illusions on people
about you but you're simply just of a
piece and living your life
[Music]
this book I read entitled lying is
fascinating especially the basic premise
which reeled me in right away is that we
often behave in ways that are guaranteed
to make us unhappy and lying itself is
so common people do it without even
thinking we don't even know what life
would be like without it and some of the
analogies are quite brilliant we
wouldn't want a car that told us we
don't need gas when we really do just
because we're too lazy to stop so why
would we want that in our lives and yet
this is what most people seem to be
doing yeah well where it gets
controversial is on the topic of White
Lies so most people acknowledge that
there is a problem or at least a
potential problem with lying in general
where you're the head of a company and
you're lying about your financials
you're engaged in a fraud you know
you're Lance Armstrong and you're taking
steroids and having press conferences
and lying about it and lying about your
teammates and you know suing them to
shut them up when they tell the world
that your line and so it's like all of
that seems pathological and people
recognize most people recognize that's
worth avoiding if you can at all help it
but they nevertheless reserve the right
to lie on all these other occasions
where they think it's actually a good
thing to do and a compassionate thing to
do and a thing that is actually
improving their relationships rather
than undermining them they call these
White Lies so much of the book is as you
know is purpose toward arguing against
this very notion of a white lie I think
if you look closely at the circumstances
where you think you are doing yourself
or anyone else a favor by misleading
another person about what you actually
believe to be true you're not and you
can discover that what you're doing is
quite obviously motivated by an
interpersonal fear with that person and
your and sometimes ramifying that fear
and allowing your relationship to
conform to it whenever you're found out
you're diminishing the trust in the
relationship the trust that the other
person could possibly have in you even
if they were consoled by your white lie
when you told it one of my favorite
examples in the book I released that
book as an e-book first it was just a
very Short hardcover book but initially
it was just a PDF that I released and
then I got reader feedback I had readers
tell me their stories about lies that
had misfired for them and the price they
had paid for lying or the lies of others
in the in their lives and one story that
came in which I used in the subsequent
edition of the book was of two women who
were out to lunch and one said to the
other brought up a third friend and one
said oh yeah I'm supposed to see her
tonight but I just can't do it I'm so
busy I don't want to go out I'm going to
call her and just tell her I can't go
out tonight so in the presence of her
friend she gets on her phone calls this
third person and gets her voicemail and
just lies about why she can't have
dinner that night she said something
about her kids being sick or whatever in
the presence of this other friend and so
now the story was delivered to me by
this friend who just watched her friend
lie with just perfect alacrity to a
friend that's kind of at the same level
and recognize in that moment that it
just subtly but rather fatally
diminished her trust in her friend I
mean she just wondered immediately she
couldn't help but wonder how often she
had been on the receiving end of that
kind of treatment what was so Insidious
about this is that it was not the kind
of lie nor was it the kind of friendship
that required that she say anything so
she never communicated that she
perceived this be an ethical problem or
does it harmed their relationship and so
the person who was lying never knew that
she had just sort of lost a friend to
some degree I mean all of this is just
so corrosive and so uninspected by most
people and so that's where the book
focuses so the commitment to telling the
truth it's definitely not the commitment
to being totally uncensored and lacking
and all tact about it's not like you
need to become a Tourette's patient and
just blur it out whatever's on your mind
it's not to say that that is actually
the phenomenology of Tourette Syndrome
but you know if that's the cartoon
version of it but it's a commitment to
saying what's true and useful the filter
is true and useful and there are certain
circumstances where you I think are wise
to worry first of all there is no whole
truth you can't say everything you think
about anything you'd be there forever
right so you're always picking and
choosing things to say and there are
circumstances where I would admit that a
slightly more paternalistic view of the
person you're talking about is relevant
so that if you're talking to a child if
you're a seven-year-old asks you you
know what is Isis you know you don't
have to immediately start telling her
about all the decapitations happening in
the Middle East there's a reason to edit
the truth and it doesn't require any
line it just requires that you see that
there's certain you know Blanks on the
map that are not appropriate to fill in
for a seven-year-old and there are
grown-ups who occasionally have to be
treated like children but we should
recognize that that's in fact what we're
doing if you think someone really can't
handle the truth about their life you
think this person is going to commit
suicide if you tell him that you know
that his wife is cheating on him or that
you didn't like his novel or something
well then you have to acknowledge that
you're dealing with someone who you
think rightly or wrongly is not a fully
competent interlocutor I mean this is
somebody who you are protecting from
himself those are really unique
circumstances when you're talking about
adults I mean far more often we're just
uncomfortable communicating what is true
because we don't think it makes us look
very good it puts us in an awkward
situation and so we're protecting
ourselves or imagine we're protecting
ourselves we're not giving the other
people in many cases an honest look at
what our situation actually is and what
our relationship actually is and what
they can expect from us in the future
and the kinds of friendships we want to
have with them and there's a mismatch
between their expectation and what in
fact you intend to do the next time
you're in a room with them so if
someone's sending you emails about you
know wanting to get together for lunch
and you just simply don't want to have
lunch with this person and you don't
want this kind of relationship with this
person and you don't even like this
person and they don't know it right I
would grant you that there are more and
less tactful more and less polite ways
to resolve that situation but the thing
that most people do is they just punt
they tell a white lie they say well you
know I'm just really busy this week
sorry I just can't do it and then you
know you get an email from that person
next week at a certain point you either
have to confront this or you just keep
making it more elaborate lies and hope
they get the point if you want to live
your life with Integrity image look at
what integrity means Integrity is a
closeness of fit between what you will
say to someone's face and what you will
say about them when they leave the room
if there's a real distance there one
you're not a good friend if that person
is in fact your friend but also you're a
scary person for others to be around and
we've all been this person we've
occupied each one of these roles now you
know what it's like when someone leaves
the room and the people who are left
immediately start talking about them
when you see someone say something that
you know there's no way they would say
that in the presence of the person who
has left you know that this person is
advertising to you something about
themselves I think diminishes your trust
of them what are they saying about you
behind your back and yet the person
who's dishing now about the other person
is rarely aware that this is in fact
what's happening they're rarely aware
that they are advertising their capacity
to you know stab others in the back I
mean there are many people who I will
say terrible things about because I
think terrible things about them but I
will also say these things to their face
I've worked very hard to do that I can't
say that honestly there's no difference
between how I would speak about someone
to their face and behind their back but
there's much less difference than there
ever has been in my life and certainly
there's much less than I see in the
lives of others and there's an immense
power to that you can be overheard by
anyone and be unembarrassed and it also
forces you to confront your mind as it
actually is I mean you if you're a petty
judgmental self-serving [ __ ] forcing
yourself to be honest with other people
holds a mirror up to that side of your
life very very quickly if the truth
about why you don't want to go out with
someone right is that you only want to
date people who are 15 years younger
than yourself and look like they're you
know fitness models well that's a truth
you have to confront if you don't give
yourself the out about lion if you can't
have recourse too well sorry I just
don't feel like being in a relationship
now whatever the LIE is is something
that you actually do have to confront
about yourself whereas the liar need in
fact never even notice it or never see
its implications when there is no
distance between who you are in private
and who you are in public there really
is no capacity for embarrassment if
you're not concealing something about
yourself that you're hoping others will
not notice you're not trying to foist
any illusions on people about you but
you're simply just of a piece and living
your life honestly representing your
views and willing to talk about anything
that's a kind of superpower it's just so
rare again I certainly can't say I've
perfectly achieved it I know what the
bullseye looks like and I know when I
land in it I know when I land just
outside it and you know just as a matter
of ethics and a matter of just personal
growth I think it's useful to become
less and less comfortable with one's own
duplicity being two-faced and saying the
thing to the person's face and having
something very different to say when
they leave the room all of those
dichotomies ultimately I think we should
find them intolerable there's a lot of
strength that comes from that just to go
back to something you just said though
about making it easier for yourself and
easier for the other person in the
moment it's worth lingering on just the
conception of easier for the other
person for a moment because it's often
making it easier in the sense that
you're telling them what they want to
hear here or telling them something more
pleasant than is in fact what's true but
you might also be causing them to waste
a tremendous amount of time or
encouraging them to waste a tremendous
amount of time where you could be
helping them to get their life on track
in a way that other people around them
aren't so the classic example for me is
when someone asks you to give your
opinion of their book or their
screenplay or you know something they've
been working on so let's say you read
their book and you think it's terrible
obviously it'd be much more convenient
for both of you if you read their book
and you thought it was great because
then you can say it was great and then
you feel good and they feel good and
your friendship is intact and there's no
problem but if a friend of yours comes
to you with something they've spent a
lot of time working on and you think
it's terrible if you think you're
helping them by sparing them this
momentary discomfort of you not
supporting their rosiest conception of
themselves yeah I think you really need
to look more closely at that because
I've been on both sides of this and I
can tell you that the people who didn't
give me honest feedback or just didn't
have good critical feedback to give were
far less helpful to me than the people
who said listen you have to tear this
thing down to the studs this is awful
you're lucky only I saw this other
people who aren't their friends are not
going to spare them their criticism the
way to think about it in these cases of
creative work what you're doing for your
friend is this thing is not yet out in
the world right it's a different
circumstance when it's out in the world
and there's nothing they can do about it
then you're having a different
conversation which is arguably harder
but if you're still in a position to
give them some help by giving them
honest feedback then you really should
give that feedback and you can always
give it in a way that acknowledges that
it's just your opinion you know you're
not omniscient you're not the ultimate
Arbiter of what is good in the world but
if you have a an informed opinion and
you have reason to think that other
people are going to share your view of
the things they're getting wrong well
then you should really just be candid
and if the person you're dealing with is
at all an adult and actually wants to be
spared future embarrassment well then
they're going to be grateful for your
candor and they're actually going to
find the friends who just glad handed
them and sent them on their way totally
useless it's always interesting to look
back on the praise one received for
things that one now thinks were terrible
imagine you've got two friends you're
doing something you really hope is going
to be great you show it to two friends
and the first friend tells you oh
everything that's wrong with this and
it's going to take you a lot of effort
to make it right but you got to get in
there and do it because in his present
form this thing is terrible and you wind
up agreeing with him right and you do
the work and you make all those
improvements but you have this other
friend who saw your first draft and said
I think it's great that person is far
less valuable to you in that capacity
and it would be an irony if the person
was simply lying to you thinking he was
going to spare you some discomfort once
you've been in business long enough you
will realize how much of business is
about trust and it's about trust because
you want to compound interest you want
to be able to work for long periods of
time with trustworthy people without
having to re-evaluate every discussion
with that and to rethink each time and
without having to constantly look over
your shoulder and so over time you
gravitate towards working with certain
kinds of people and similarly those
people will gravitate towards working
with other ethical quote-unquote people
so being ethical turns out to be a
selfish imperative you want to be
ethical because it attracts the other
long-term players in the network and
then they want to do business with you
and if you build a good enough
reputation for being ethical eventually
people will pay you just to do deals
through you because you're the one who
validate and ensure the deals by your
presence because you wouldn't be
involved with low quality stuff so being
ethical actually pays off in the long
run but it's the very long run in the
short run being unethical pays off which
is why so many people go for it it's a
greedy algorithm but you can be ethical
simply because you're a long-term greedy
and I can even outline a framework for
different parts of so-called ethics just
based on the idea of long-term
selfishness for example you want to be
honest because it leaves you with a
clear mind you don't have two threads
running in your head one is the lies
that you told you to keep track of and
the other one is what you're saying you
just have to think about one thing at a
time so you have more energy to think
about that thing so you're a clear
thinker also by being honest you're
rejecting the people who only want to
hear the Pretty Lies so you force those
people out of your network and sometimes
it's painful like friends and family but
long term you create room for the people
who like you exactly the way that you
are so that is a selfish reason to be
honest for example in negotiations if
you're the kind of person person who
always tries to get the best deal for
yourself you will win a lot of very
early deals and it'll feel very good but
on the other hand there are a few people
who will recognize that you're always
scrabbling and not acting fairly and
they will tend to avoid you over time
those people end up being the deal
makers in the network because people go
to them for a fair shake or to figure
out what's fair and so if you are
cutting people Fair deals you don't get
paid in the short term but in the long
term everybody wants to deal with you
and you end up being a Market Hub you
have more information you have trust you
have reputation and people end up doing
deals through you a lot of wisdom is
just realized in the long-term
consequences of your actions and so the
longer term you're willing to look the
wiser that you're going to seem to
everybody around you my takeaways are
the following if you want to build a
long lasting healthy relationship avoid
lying always give honest feedback
especially when you're in a position in
which your opinions can help someone to
self-esteem is just a reputation that
you have with yourself
you will always know
play long-term games with long-term
people or returns in life weathering
wealth relationships or knowledge come
from compound interests
few Delights can equal the mere presence
of one whom we trust utterly George
McDonald thanks for watching if you
enjoyed the greeting content in this
video you will love our newsletter where
you can get in your email all the
greeting content plus the latest things
that I've been pondering to subscribe
always for free find the link below in
the description
foreign